[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Megan
kicks us off in Kansas City Megan
welcome to the
show Megan are you with us hey yes there
she
is what's going
on um so my husband um spends on average
about ,000 a month um at gas
stations um for you know snacks drinks
um a majority of that though is for
chewing tobacco oh and my question um is
how can I help him
become how can I help him work towards
becoming more financially responsible um
so that we're not worrying you know how
we're going to make it till the end of
the month with bills and other
priorities how long has this been going
on
for um it's been going on for a few
years um it has gotten worse though
within the last year or so is he using
more chewing tobacco what do you think
the pro the problem is there um
definitely more chewing tobacco um he
goes through maybe two to three cans a
day and that can be pretty pricey um and
it's it hurts us financially um as you
could probably imagine I assume you've
had conversations with them about this
how do those go
yes um they they don't go very well it
usually starts an argument um he uh he
has tried to quit multiple times through
the last several years um we've done
medical we've we've we've spoken to
doctors um he's put been put on
prescriptions he's tried the patches
everything um he's tried quit quitting
cold turkey and just nothing has worked
and um especially since we now have a
family I really thought that that would
help out in getting him to quit but it
hasn't so what why did the patches not
work if it's given him the same unless
he just the patches can't possibly give
what three cans a day is giving him yeah
um I think it's just it all boils down
to you know deep down he really doesn't
want to quit no he loves he likes it
yeah and I just can't really find
anything that gives him that push to do
you know if is it is it relaxing to him
what is the benefit is it a buzz that
chills him out what's going on I well he
does have
ADD so um I think it just chills him out
but also it's become such a habit um and
he I think it's just that yeah that buzz
maybe yeah well and I wonder if there's
not something else below the surface CU
what doctors are trying to treat they
can't treat feels like this is something
in his soul in his heart that's what I
think is that true no I agree with you
what does he do for work um he is an
HVAC technician yeah does he like his
job oh yes very much so yeah this is
deeper than this this is deeper so
here's the deal
um we got to get that part figured out
or any Financial advice or any
conversational or communication advice
we give you is is largely going to fall
on deaf ears because he's defensive now
uh however I do think there's a money
piece to it but I think it has to be
whatever's going on that is requiring
you to medicate yourself this way is
going to break
us that's the depth of this and and so
we've got to get to that and then the
financial piece will take care of itself
because he doesn't have to
medicate yes so in the meantime since we
can't solve that George I I want to know
what George thinks I I think this is a
so I'm gonna come back to this in a sec
I want to come back to the conversation
of what she might say but I want to
bring in the financial in this case
giving her advice this is such a
sensitive issue that's got a lot of
depth to
it could she get him on board with all
right you got to go get a side hustle to
the tune of a, a month to cover this
medication I am I think that's a fair
ask what do you think George yeah I mean
there with addiction it's not as simple
as saying hey we're going to we're going
to cut them off yeah and so I I still
think I'm not a medical professional I
think cold turkeyy is the way to go and
I think it starts with this conversation
of you going listen this is going to
deteriorate your health I want you
around to see our kids grow up I want us
to actually hit our financial goals is
derailing us financially for you to be
spending this way and by the way gas
stations are one of the worst places to
buy all of this stuff it's the highest
cost and so if he's going to do this
he's got to be smarter about it than
just impulsively stopping by the gas
station every four hours and so he's got
to find a way to curb the spending even
if it's hey we're cutting back no more
food snacks drinks all this stuff yeah I
I think that's the key you have to say
babe I'm worried about this and you're
going to have to get more involved in
the finances do you guys have combined
bank
accounts no and because of that reason
yeah and I know that's something I've
struggled with um I've taken control
somewhat of his uh bank account um just
so that I can monitor his spending and
every month it's the same thing when we
sit down and have that talk like hey
you're spending way too much and it's
just yeah it's is this on a credit card
a debit card debit okay and so he's got
the money but it's his income and he's
just spending down his account every
month doing this yes and we've even
tried with with um having him send um me
uh like a certain percentage of his
paychecks that I would then put into
savings or it would go towards um bills
for that month I think you need to tell
him listen I didn't sign up to be
married to a child that I have to
monitor in
babysit you need to care about this
family more than you care about your
chewing tobacco habit and I need you to
show me that conversation yeah and if if
you guys need to go to counseling to
deal with the the marital issues beneath
this I think if you don't it's going to
cause more resentment and this marriage
isn't going to survive this George is
right cuz this is going to just compound
every month for the next what another
three years of this well you're not
going to solve it you can't solve it he
has to understand how afraid you are how
exhausted you are how it's affecting you
guys how it's affecting your marriage
and what that's going to have an impact
on the rest of his life and then he's
going to have to get to the bottom of
what's going on with him which is
causing the medication of the tobacco
and then you guys have to fix what's
already
been in some ways bruised and broken
with you two all of that has to happen
or this this spending isn't going to
stop yeah even if we go hey tell them to
get in bulk at Walmart well that might
be a Band-Aid that might save us 200
bucks a month but it doesn't solve the
real problem
here you know I agree I'm sorry you're
going through this Megan I again I wish
we had a magic answer for you I think
it's a come to Jesus meeting I really do
yes I I agree and I know addiction is
one of the most difficult things a
person can deal with and I encourage him
to call Dr John deloney show to walk
through that piece of it and if he's
willing to call he's really serious
about this um we can get him on the line
with our friend Dr John to help him work
through that but that's the only answer
to this money problem is him overcoming
this addiction create your free every
dooll budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life